-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here!
You made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
I want to say congrats
to the Cincinnati Bengals
and Los Angeles Rams
on advancing to Super Bowl LVI.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Before the season,
the Bengals' odds of winning
the Super Bowl were 150-1.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
To give you an idea,
there are better odds
of finding a rapid test at CVS.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
Than going to the Super Bowl.
-Wow!
[ Applause ]
-That's true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I'm sorry."
-"Nope."
And this is crazy.
The Super Bowl is being played
in Los Angeles
at the Rams' home stadium.
[ Cheers ]
That's right.
Even NFL players
are working from home.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
We're two weeks away
from the game,
and experts are wondering,
if a Super Bowl doesn't have
Tom Brady,
can it still be called
the Super Bowl?
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
But this is the Bengals
first Super Bowl appearance
since the '80s.
-Ooh.
-A lot has changed since then.
Back then, inflation was high,
there was tension with Russia,
and our president
was in his late 70s.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and I saw that during
the Bengals/Chiefs games --
This just made me laugh.
Did you see the announcements
over at CBS?
-Oh, yeah.
-They have a great crew.
They're awesome over there.
But at CBS, they're doing
the halftime, talking about
the stats and all that stuff.
But they were just
in the worst spot
you could possibly be
on the field to talk.
But take a look
at the halftime report.
Look at this.
-...as we welcome
Grammy-nominated
singer-songwriter Walker Hayes!
-...this game...
[ Country music plays loudly ]
They score, they go down...
-At what point do you consider
blitzing Patrick Mahomes?
-I have no idea
what you just said.
I can't hear a thing
anybody is saying.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
The speakers
are right behind them!
-Yeah.
It's the first football game
where the announcers
got concussions.
Unbelievable.
[ Laughter ]
You know the closed-captioning
guy was in a white-hot panic,
like, "I can't -- I don't --
I don't know what to --"
[ Laughter ]
It sounds like when your friend
calls you from every concert.
Like, "Man, it's great!
Yeah!"
[ Laughter ]
When the music stopped,
Boomer Esiason
was still yelling
at full volume.
"And that's why Mahomes has to
have more of a running game!"
They go...
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the big football
story form this weekend
wasn't the games.
On Saturday, ESPN reported
that Tom Brady is retiring.
But then --
[ Cheers ]
But then,
conflicting reports came out
that said
Brady hasn't decided yet.
[ Laughter ]
This is what happens
when you let the CDC
announce your retirement.
[ Laughter ]
You just don't know --
[ Cheers and applause ]
6 feet, 3 feet, 5 days...
[ Applause ]
Brady was like, "I just
wanted to see who was happy
so I can destroy them."
[ Laughter ]
Let's switch gears.
Over the weekend,
former president Trump
held a rally in Texas
where he talked about
running for President
and said that if he won,
he might pardon
the January 6th rioters.
[ Audience groans ]
Even the rioters were like,
"Oh, no,
I don't think he can say that."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, there's no way --
no better way to announce
a presidential run than saying,
"I'll empty the jails."
[ Laughter ]
Well, the East Coast
is recovering
from a massive blizzard
that hit this weekend.
Boston actually got one of its
biggest snowstorms ever,
but that didn't stop people
from going out.
Watch this.
-Have you heard the news
about Tom Brady?
-Yes.
-What do you make of all that?
-I don't know.
I don't know.
Is Gronk next then, I guess?
-I thought he had
a couple more years, maybe.
-Where are you guys
trying to go right now?
-We're trying to find
an open Dunkin' Donuts.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
-Can't find them.
-Come on!
-No, dude --
-That's real.
-Oh, my God.
-We did not do anything
to that tape.
That is real.
[ Laughter ]
Tom Brady, Dunkin' Donuts.
If they snuck in David Ortiz,
they would have summoned
the ghost of Sam Adams.
[ Laughter and applause ]
How Boston is that?
Fantastic.
[ Applause ]
You might have a problem
when you're willing to put on
ski goggles just to get
a pineapple Coolatta.
[ Laughter ]
But they weren't the only ones
who braved
the weekend's blizzard.
I saw that a couple
in Rhode Island
actually got married outside
during the storm.
Here's the happy couple there
right there.
Yeah.
And this is real.
Here's everyone
who showed up to the wedding.
[ Laughter ]
You know it's cold when your
"something blue"
are your guests.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man who lives
on a lake in Canada
snapped a photo of a figure
that formed when waves
splashed onto the shore
and froze around a lamp post.
People are saying it looks like
the Grim Reaper.
Take a look at this.
-Ooh.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Everyone thought it was
the Grim Reaper
until they heard grandpa
whisper, "Help. Help me."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, did you guys hear about
the Nissan recall?
It's not good.
Here, check this out.
-A massive recall alert
to tell you about.
Nissan is recalling
more than 793,000
small SUVs in the U.S. because
water can get into the wiring
and, in rare cases,
could start a fire.
-What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
A fire?
-Oh, hey,
it's Tariq Trotter, everybody.
Tariq!
[ Cheers and applause ]
What are you doing out here?
Your interview isn't until
later in the show?
-Well, no,
I just bought a Nissan,
so I heard you talking about it,
and I rushed out here.
-Yeah, well,
sorry about the recall.
-It's fine. Look, I still have
my trusty Hyundai.
It's one of their
newer vehicles.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh" what?
-Roll the clip.
-Hyundai sounds the alarm about
three of its newer vehicles.
There's an issue
with the windshield
that can cause it to break off
while driving.
[ Laughter ]
-Break off?
Come on, that's insane.
-Yeah, I'm sorry about that,
Tariq.
-Man, I can't handle
any more bad news.
-There's got to be something
that you're looking forward to.
-I mean,
I am excited for lunch tomorrow.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I bought a bunch of this
really good
vegan mac and cheese.
[ Laughter ]
It's in my pantry.
-And check your pantry.
It's listed as
vegan mac and cheese,
but it's not actually vegan,
and it might even be dangerous.
[ Laughter ]
-Dangerous?
-You should probably
throw it out.
-What else do I even have
in my kitchen right now?
Just a bag
of frozen chopped spinach.
-Recall alert -- this time
for frozen chopped spinach.
-Come on.
You know what?
Forget it.
I'm just gonna sit back
and relax on my new beach chair.
I got one in light blue
and another one in red.
-We've got a recall alert
in that specific beach chair.
Where you probably bought it,
and why you should
stop using it.
-Man, I'm getting so mad!
Man, I just want to --
I just want to take
a chainsaw and go berserk.
-Well, wait, wait!
Hold up.
What kind of chainsaw?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I have a Dewalt DWCS600
18-inch corded chainsaw.
-More than 8,000 Dewalt DWCS600
18-inch corded chainsaws
are being recalled.
-That's it, man!
I'm done!
I am done!
[ Chainsaw motor whirring ]
-Tariq -- Tariq is gonna cool
down before his interview.
His musical, "Black No More,"
is playing now
though February 27th
at the Pershing Square
Signature Center.
Stick around.
We'll be right back,
with "Puppy Predictors."